[Musique]
depuis sa création la délégation aux
entreprises est guidée par un objectif
cardinal enrichir les réflexions et les
travaux du Sénat à travers une approche
concrète pragmatique de la vie des
entreprises dans leur diversité il
s'agit d'informer le Sénat sur la
situation et les perspectives de nos PME
et de nos PMI d'identifier les obstacles
à leur développement et bien sûr de
proposer des évolutions du cadre
législatif et réglementaire
cette journée sera un moment fort de ce
qui fait le cœur de métier de la
délégation le dialogue avec les
entreprises n'hésitez pas à nous
contacter pour faire remonter
d'éventuelles difficultés liées à
l'application concrète de texte
législatif ou réglementaire
je pense qu'il est largement temps que
l'ensemble des acteurs travaillent main
dans la main et qu'on décidote d'un côté
les grands acteurs de l'État et leur
responsable de l'autre côté
l'administration et tout le monde doit
être dans un mouvement
dynamique et favorable
j'étais ravie des intervenants étaient
de qualité on avait vraiment une variété
d'intervenants
qu'à la fois des entrepreneurs avec un
représentant du ministère de Bercy qui a
eu beaucoup par réponse à des questions
mais qui a joué le jeu et c'est toujours
intéressant d'avoir
ces réponses et d'avoir cet échange
il y a une forme de distance justement
entre ce pouvoir législatif et
l'entreprise au quotidien donc c'est
toujours mieux quand c'est incarné et
quand on peut avoir un contact direct ce
qui est le cas aujourd'hui
[Musique]
si on avait un message à faire passer
faites confiance à vos entreprises
françaises elles sont réactives elles
sont capables de se mettre en oeuvre
donc faites leur confiance et
donnez-nous la liberté d'aller plus vite
à mettre en place nos solutions qu'on a
pu développer
[Musique]